within the CIA how do you know that well
I did research the book started this way
it was obvious that there was a channel
of leaks coming out of the CIA after the
war on terror began most of them were
anti-bush leaks they were programs they
were classified reports and there
started to be grumbling among
conservatives that Bush has enemies and
the CIA and it became the father of
columns and pundants and then in 2004
Porter Goss goes over to the CIA he's
the beast bush's first CIA director
really he stayed with George Tenet and
Porter Goss really gets just chewed up
by the bureaucracy he goes over there to
reform the clandestine service that was
his mission and instead he he they rebel
against him he tries to change one
person in the clandestine service
organization and that person rebels
calls his staff a bunch of Hill pukes
and resins in protest that causes other
resignations and all of a sudden Porter
Goss as the looks of a massacre on his
hands and and press stories that he's
incompetent he's politicizing the agency
all these leaks coming out of the agency
and that's when John McCain Senator John
McCain is watching all this and he
declares that the CIA is is a rogue
agency that that it's off doing its own
thing and not being a team player in any
regard and then you had a letter from
pete Hoekstra the one-time chairman of
the House Intelligence Committee he
writes to the president and a private
letter and warns him that he has enemies
in the CIA that they're undermining the
war they're undermining the
administration and you need to do
something about it well it's tough to do
something about it you can't change
bureaucracies he inherited that but
based on that based on that background I
decided to do an investigation and I
found generally a pattern of smears
coming out of the CIA directed a key
Bush officials that badly damaged their
careers damaged their effectiveness the
flow of leaks of classified programs and
other things that again damage the
administration whether you I I happen to
like leaks you know but but if you put
it into a pattern with with some of the
smear campaigns it shows you that the
President had enemy
is within the CIA then I then I
discovered that there's actually a
private Association of former CIA
officers that was formed prints
principally for the for the purpose of
attacking Bush as a war criminal and the
leader of it promotes the idea that the
government did 911 and then lastly
there's just a pattern of where the the
CIA bureaucracy just did not do the
right thing if they had done the right
thing and followed proper procedures the
president the administration would not
have been embarrassed in a number of
cases and I think the plane Wilson case
is a prime example where the vice
president wanted an inquiry into Africa
and uranium and Iraq it was very
rational inquiry and instead of doing a
professional intelligence investigation
the bureaucracy sends ambassador Joe
Wilson down there and doesn't tell the
director doesn't tell the White House
and the rest is history so to speak grow
and Scarborough our guests for the next
25 minutes or so if you want to talk to
him about his book and is research
within the CIA 2027 37000 to four
Democrats 20 27 37 00 01 for Republicans
and independents 20 to 60 to 80 205 why
the resistance what's the crux I that
the CIA became I didn't do a poll and
it's just an assertion I make in the
book that the CIA became a more liberal
place in the 90s that the 90s were in a
way of dark ages for the CIA the
clandestine service was cut drastically
they cut way down on recruiting spies
which is their real mission they closed
bases around the around the world we all
know the CIA works out of stations but
they also work out a basis for example
there's five or six in Iraq today not in
addition to the station well they
started rolling those up they did not
invest in new technologies they did not
shift language in a language training so
so the CIA was not really ready for this
new threat the new types of languages
that they had to learn and George Tenet
himself said in his book that the CIA
was in Chapter 11 at the end of the 90s
of a very damning comment about his own
agency but I think at the same time
during the Clinton administration more
democratic loyalists went to the sea
I a in the bureaucracy and so there were
elements as pete Hoekstra calls them
ourselves of people who were just
politically opposed to sort of the
Reaganite hard lighter hardliners who
came in with the Bush administration I
think that was the motive what is the
agency done then in light of a new
leadership there well Porter Goss was
the new leader and he got expelled by
the bureaucracy I mean the leaks against
him were so great and so continuous that
he became ineffective basically he also
had problems with John Negroponte the
Director of National Intelligence they
did not hit it off so that the the
current director general Hayden is
rebuilding the sebree building the
clandestine force there they're adding
that I don't maybe a third of the of the
whole CIA is going to be added in the
next couple of years and he's he's begun
an email campaign as sort of an open
email exchange with the clandestine
service and everybody and he and he said
in an interview with Brian lamb on
c-span I want to get the CIA out of the
press source business so to me that
means he's trying to stop the leaking
against the administration so how does
he go about changing the morale that
you've seen demonstrated in this book
and how does he change that well one way
is this you're doing a great job you
know what are your problems i'll try to
fix them this email exchange and they're
bringing a lot of new people in and it's
going to take you don't rebuild an
agency in in 10 years you don't take a
second lieutenant in making a colonel in
a couple of years so it's going to take
a while and you you know if you if you
want to recruit spies if you want to
penetrate al-qaeda you need experience
clandestine service officers who know
how to do this and they still don't have
enough of them so which is going to it's
going to take time is the nature of
intelligence gathering and proving
within the CIA I think it is I think
it's begun to get better i think the
watch list that they've created the
National Counterterrorism Center where
they have thousands and thousands of
names of people connected to terrorism
that's that's kept by the FBI it's
shared by the state it was shared with
state FAA it's keeping people out of the
country who shouldn't come into the
country we didn't have that before the
Baghdad station which was pretty
dysfunctional for the first three years
of the war it was inexperienced
it wasn't keen on the mission morale was
low it's doing better today and in the
book I have I have a criticism of the
CIA operation and Bay in Baghdad by a
Army Intelligence colonel who was
watching the whole thing unfold for
three or four years and it's pretty
devastating critique of how bad it was
in those first four years our guest is
the national security correspondent for
the washington examiner and for those
who may not know what that is what is it
well it's a fairly new newspaper in town
it's part of a three paper chain that's
going to get bigger it's going to get
larger it's been in town a little over
two years it's a free paper it's a
different business model and it in its
focus is local news but but it's
building a national staff now bill
Sammon covers the White House Susan
furry CEO was reached recently hired to
cover Congress and I cover the Pentagon
and is there a website for it sure
examiner.com will get you there and then
there's the San Francisco paper and a
Baltimore paper and there soon to be
more papers first call for you comes
from denham springs louisiana caller go
ahead yes i like them asked McCarver to
a very question well the first question
would be who owns his three papers I'd
like to know that fact and next is where
all these leaks you're speaking off
coming out of the CIA where any of them
not the truth and one other item why do
you think that all the people left the
CIA because all of a sudden they got
pulled off of a bin Laden in Afghanistan
and they want to show them to Iraq
that's read most of the people have gone
from the CIA mr. Scarboro the the papers
owned by clarity media which is owned by
Phil Anschutz a fairly wealthy
capitalist who also owns a high-tech
firm soccer teams moviemaking business
so he's the owner and he's the founder
of the washington examiner on why were
they the truth well that's that's really
part of the point of my book i mean if
you're leaking against an official who
has done something wrong then that's a
debt to me is a good leak that's how the
that's how the city is supposed to work
but when you're smearing people with
unsubstantiated charges which dog them
the rest of their careers
which are ultimately proven untrue that
that's that's a campaign that's what
that is that that's just a political
campaign and that happened to too often
my research shows now on seeds on the
CIA and their manpower and the 90s the
reason the CIA people left the CIA is
they were pushed out the door there was
a there was a there was a campaign on to
slash the CIA's budget and extract
budget savings for other priorities and
so people were told to leave and not
that many people were brought in to
replace them now the caller has a point
about Afghanistan and Iraq there is no
doubt that Iraq has pulled resources out
of Afghanistan the I point out in the
book how robust the the Joint Special
Operations Command is in Iraq where it's
hunting all these high-value targets but
how threadbare it is in Afghanistan
because it because we know the JSOC does
not have enough people demand both
countries at the levels that they would
probably like it and also in the book I
talk about the fact since they can't get
into Pakistan anyway since there are
since there are limits on their rules of
engagement it doesn't make a lot of
sense to have a lot of those terror
hunters there at the current moment
anyway uh Jacksonville Florida yes sir I
do have a question for you first of all
I would like to thank you for writing
the book which I'm very interested in
reading but I would like to make it
aware to see people within our country
that it is not only within our CIA this
is also happening today within our
military in Jacksonville Florida we just
had a lieutenant commander Matthew diet
that was court-martialed for giving out
the information from Guantanamo Bay he
was second in command and here's a very
staunch Democrat which I was for 32
years but after personally knowing what
had transpired I can no longer support
the Democratic Party they are destroying
this country from within our own
military today and I think it's just a
shame that this is going on it does not
get out to the news media and the
American people need to really take a
hard look and
see who they want to stand up for this
country and I thank you and I will stand
by and listen to what you have to say
mr. Scarborough well I mean I don't want
to condemn one party or the other I did
it's my belief that the inside the CIA
there or there were political people
that just don't like the president and
that's why some of these leaks have
occurred you there was a one massive
leak investigation that Porter Goss
began when he came to the CIA one of the
first things Porter Goss did was he went
into the bubble the secure auditorium
there and he asked the people to stop
leaking against the administration and
he then ordered an IG investigation to
try to find out where the leaks were
coming from and we know you know one
person was kind of spit out of the
bureaucracy because of that someone a
woman analyst was retired early and she
it turns out that she was a John Kerry
supporter she had given money to the
thousands of dollars to the Democratic
Party and that kind of reconfirmed
conservative suspicions about the CIA
and that there are party activists at
the CIA damaging the president we're
going to talk later about the bill today
on the house that would enact some of
the provisions that the 911 Commission
made one of the provisions calls for the
disclosure of intelligence budgets
between 2007 2008 what do you think of
that passes what's the long-term effect
of that effect I think that's a good
idea I look the number floats around
anyway so why not do it I think one of
the problems with the 90s was there was
hardly any debate that I recall on what
was happening to the CIA because its
budget is so secret so there were closed
hearings with the house Intel Committee
of the Senate Intel committee where they
would talk about cutting the budget and
what is this doing to your operational
ability but it was not done in the open
so it came to a surprise surprise to a
lot of people when the 911 Commission
report came out and they started reading
about what had happened to the CIA in
the 90s and how they almost stopped
recruiting spies and so I think it'd be
great if we had more light shed on the
budget and in manpower even for Rowan
Scarborough next call chestertown
Maryland good morning good morning it's
a pleasure to get through thank you so
much for c-span
I have a question for mr. Scarborough in
light of I just learned recently that of
the manpower that's in the CIA that
approximately half of them have less
than five years experience and you
indicated that it's more effective on
intelligence and how can this be much of
the CIA duties of them privatize that
the private corporation and I'm having
much trouble believing it's more
effective well I'm not giving a I'm not
giving a rousing statement that it's
more effective I just think compared to
2001 it's in better shape but i will add
that in the in the book I talk about a
trip that Peter hoekstra congressman
hoekstra earlier this year took to the
Middle East and North Africa visiting
stations there that's sort of the
epicenter of the war on terror and
al-qaeda and he came back and wrote
another letter to the White House saying
how appalled he was at the condition of
these stations that they were staffed
primarily by rookies or people with
little experience that people were still
just punching a ticket that were going
to spend 15 months in the station and
then go on to another place and to him
the idea of reform was to keep people in
these critical stations for a while so
they can learn the country so they can
develop sources after all what we want
the clandestine service to do is get
scoops like it like a newspaper reporter
find out new things try to penetrate an
organization and then get that
information back to Langley and and
huckster said it still was not being
done in 2007 our guest is Rowand
Scarborough is the national security
correspondent for the washington
examiner examiner.com is the
publication's website if you want to
check out his writing and other writings
by that publication again examiner.com
Miami Florida yes sir muy mr. scarbrow
um I have a question were you able to
determine if um if the leadership of the
Democratic Party let's say Nancy Pelosi
and Harry Reid if were you able to trace
any of the leaks back to them thank you
no no and I'm not the league police as I
say I as a reporter I like leaks I mean
in this book I have some leaks I talk
about new ways that we are
tracking terrorists in Afghanistan and
then and Iraq but it just fit a pattern
for the book the leaks exist but people
write about leaks I mean the plane the
the Wilson plane scandal was a leak and
we wrote about it for three or four
years so but I did not seek to determine
who done it so just be trying to find a
story this morning and I can't find it
yet but they were it's in one of the
papers this morning I will find it but
there are concerns by the United States
about the saw Saudi Arabia and their
government helping more with the aspect
of terrorism and getting more involved
in it I'll find the story but can you
paint your experience into that
situation well Saudi Arabia is a mixed
bag it was sort of the intellectual
center of radical Islam that rose up in
Egypt in the 50s and the 60s they were
talk about a wake-up call I me 911 was
our wake-up call Saudi Arabia needed
three or four or five wake-up calls
until they actually acknowledged that
they had a significant al-qaeda presence
in their country and they're not doing
enough to help us in Iraq that's the
feeling of the Bush administration that
they could do more with the Sunni
population there to influence they're
not doing enough to keep suicide bombers
or foreign fighters from coming out of
their country and going into into Iraq
and they're not doing enough to pressure
Syria and pressure well primarily Syria
to close that border because most of the
suicide bombers come in through Syria
there there are three basic routes that
they use and Syria by and large stands
by and lets them coordinate inside their
country and then cross the border
another story this morning kind of looks
at the ties between China and Iran and
painting it is concerns by the United
States especially about the trade of
Technology oh sure I mean I Iran has
been a client of China for a long time
they got the components to make weapons
of mass destruction chemical weapons
from Chinese companies China's help them
help them with their missile programs
China's in the arm business they can get
hard cash for selling weapons around the
world and some of those weapons are now
showing up in Iraq and killing our
troops so we it stuffed it's tough to
stop the arms market these these these
rockets and
k 47s can move in many many ways and the
Chinese government not oh not all the
time knows that they're moving out of
China and moving into Iran but it's very
lucrative and it's very hard to stop
Rutherford New Jersey 40 and Scarborough
hi how you doing today um my question is
basically I was going to add something
else but in light of what you were
talking about the Saudi Arabia saying i
figured i would talk about asking a
question about the story that came out
yesterday from the EU saying how the EU
would no longer be sharing information
about their passenger list with the
united states and i just want to ask him
if he feels that the CIA is doing such a
better job why is it that the other
countries around the world are not
sharing information with us any longer
thank you I'll have to plead ignorance
on that story I missed it I've been on
this I've been on this book tour and and
have not done a whole lot of reading but
I was under the assumption that Europe
was being very cooperative and helping
us a symbol our watch list I bad as I
understand it we don't have a watch list
for people traveling you know from Spain
to France but our watch list is for
people that are going to be on an
international flight into this country
or maybe into a country where we are
fighting now which is Iraq in
Afghanistan The Washington Post reports
that the United States and the European
Union have agreed to expand a security
program that shares personal data about
the millions of a us-bound airline
passengers a year potentially including
information about a person's race
ethnicity religion and help for our
guests our next call Austin Texas go
ahead please oh yes thank you for taking
my call I think that what Bush has done
going to Iraq was the worst thing this
country has ever done it is called more
terrorism a dictatorship by definition
is stable so when you destabilize a
country by taking out the dictator as
bad as it was a dictatorship was stable
he has completely he has completely
caused a mess in the Middle East and
cause more tear terrorism than ever
before he should have left that country
alone nobody in their right mind no
other country was with
except maybe the Brits and now they're
not with us when we have destabilized
that area this is the worst thing this
country could ever have done and you
cannot first of all you cannot get any
consensus with democracy those factions
those clans have been fighting he said
each other to save were going there for
democracy that again that is crazy mr.
Scarborough oh I agree that we never
should have gone into Iraq the way we
went into Iraq we were totally
unprepared for what we found there there
was no real security plan to secure the
population there was no grand political
plan we went in with rose-colored
glasses we thought the the elite of Iraq
the educated and all the sex would come
together and just kind of form a
government and be so grateful that Sodom
was gone that within a year we'd have a
functioning democracy and we know that
didn't happen so the they missed the
miscalculations of going into Iraq were
of historic proportions I disagree that
the dictatorships are stabilized Saddam
Hussein was not a stabilizing force in
the Middle East he had invaded the two
countries he wanted to invade Saudi
Arabia until we put the 82nd airborne
into that country and all all of his
intentions were to beat UN sanctions
corrupt them and restart his weapons of
mass destruction as soon as the world
the lost interest so I I don't think
Sodom was saying was a stabilizing
figure Chicago Illinois good morning mr.
scarbrow Lorna I'm a former Army Ranger
and I was just going to bring up the
subject that you just brought up about
Saudi Arabia I do have a couple
questions my first question is how does
the CIA's intelligence reflect with
military intelligence our military
intelligence and what about the state
department's internal consoler
operations which deals with a lot of
intelligence and especially with our
so-called allies Saudi Arabia and first
off I'm
on a dimension up you know you said
about the leaks in the CIA I understand
the political frame because I believe
quite a few of the individuals that were
in the caar CIA were part of the Quentin
administration and plain proved it when
she wanted her husband moved to Africa
but with the Society's people need to
look at the history and see that the
Saudis you know everybody's talking
tribes sunni-shiite whatever if you look
at history the societies are I mean the
Sunnis are Babylonian okay and the
Shiites are Persians and the Kurds are
the old needs that helped wiped out all
of those tribes down there so why is in
Saudi Arabia putting the pressure on to
unify the Sunnis with an especially with
Syria and using any type of political
gain that they have to try to keep the
Persians from holding on to the reins of
power well as I mentioned earlier the
the Bush administration believes that
the kingdom can do more in Iraq there
there we talk about purvis Musharraf in
Pakistan walking a tightrope he's trying
to do to conduct the war against
militants but not but keep a lid on the
militants that would like to overthrow
his government well the Saudis have the
same problem they've them they are in
Islamic Kingdom and they have militant
they have militant actors in their
country that would like to overthrow
their government so they want to make
sure that people don't flow that way and
continue to be loyal to the kingdom
that's one of the reasons they're not
involved as in Iraq as much as our our
government would like them to be you
mentioned intelligence services there
are 62 agencies there's 16 of them part
of the friction that that really began
with the CIA and the Pentagon after the
911 attack was that Rumsfeld started
building up military intelligence and he
the summoned the CIA he began to look as
a rival as a rival that he was actually
creating his own CIA at the
gun and I think that was part of the
reason there began began this charge and
counter-charge culture that went on for
three years after nine eleven Potomac
Falls Virginia I please I hope you give
me enough time I'm a retired
intelligence officer I could tear this
book apart number one sir you don't know
anything at all about tour of duties for
intelligence officers it's not 15 months
has never been 15 months it's a two-year
tour or a three-year tour I don't know
where you did your research on that
second on Valerie plane she was covert
and she could not have had the authority
to send her husband to Africa he was had
an expert on background in dealing with
that because he was part of the
Diplomatic Service that would have to go
up to the higher change in order to send
him to Africa and the third thing when
you talk about polarization Porter golf
came over there and he bought a couple
of people who had left the CIA because
they didn't get promoted and they turn
it into their own little political
basketball basketball going back and
forth there are dedicated intelligence
officers to take their families overseas
risk their lives change their whole
lifestyle and our dedicated American
patriot caller which branch of the
intelligence did you serve that I was in
the CIA and I was in the do thank you
yeah well I agree with her there a lot
of patriotic CIA officers out risking
their lives every day and the book does
not say they weren't on the tours pete
Hoekstra spoint was that when you take
out vacation time and learning time it
boiled down to about 15 months in a
country before they moved on and that's
what he's trying to get the do to
reverse on Valerie Plame I agree she was
a covered person she was occur to me she
was a classified person there's no doubt
about it my point is and if you talk to
officers in the CIA that trip should
have been handled that way when the vice
president asked for a major inquiry into
what
Iraq in Africa are making overtures
about uranium you need to do an
intelligence investigation that's my
point Rowan Scarborough is the author of
sabotage America